about the
dress
uh today I will be talking about testing
threshold in random geometric graphs and
this is based on Joy and work with
Sudan's mohanti Soleil Shram and
Elizabeth yeah and the students until we
like you
so I think in flavor this will be quite
different from the previous talk but but
we'll see yeah and maybe I should remark
that if anything is not clear maybe I
stop me and ask because I'm not exactly
sure what's everyone's background so
this is a this workshops Topic's more
like General
than the previous two uh okay so I'll
just actually directly jump into a
definition and maybe motivate a little
bit later after we see the definition so
uh the object we're studying here is
like a random geometric graphs so this
this model is simple in the following
way so specifically there's a unit
Vector sorry unit saphir in dimension D
and we denote it by a c minus one what
we do is we sample endpoints on this
unit sphere
and then the graph the edges of the
graph is sampled by connecting two
points X and Y if and only if their
inner product is greater than some fresh
total
and Tau of p is selected so that the
marginal probability of an edge exists
um in this graph is exactly B
here we can see there could be more um
or points being generated and uh okay I
want to make two remarks here that will
be related to later
topics in the talk so first is that this
Tau this threshold like uh this uh
basically this threshold that controls
the correlation between the two vectors
decreases as D increases so you'll get
smaller and smaller CD increases
so in other words like the dependency
between the two uh
the between the two vectors are also
getting smaller and smaller once D
increases
okay another thing I want to comment on
is that okay if we focus on a Vertex
let's say y uh the locus of all the
points that can have an edge with Y are
precisely uh uh all the points that
basically land in this severe cap around
y because this is uh this is a
collection of all points having in a
product greater than Tau with y
so that's the two points I want to point
out here that clear
okay
so uh okay and later in this talk this
model I just defined it will be given
this notation gldnp so it depends on the
dimension of the sphere and also like
probability p
now here we only consider deal as a
function of n actually the answer is yes
so uh okay why so why are we interested
in such a model
well such a motto we've seen it's uh
quite different from like let's say
early training model or even like the
regular graph model which are usually
I guess the common model studied in many
like average case problems and the uh
construction of things
so the key property that's different is
this model introduces dependency between
adjacent edges in the graph specifically
we see here that basically if we know
that in the graph an edge exists between
the vertex A and B and A and C that
means essentially B and C as we
commented before will need to land in
the severe cap around a
and because of that the probability of
BC having an edge in between them is
much higher than the probability that a
random BC on the sphere will have an
edge in between them
so this probability is much bigger than
p
which is the marginal probability of an
edge exist if they just come from two
random points atmosphere
okay so what's good about this
dependency well okay so two motivations
one is arguably it's a better
approximation for real world and network
data and models uh then a model like
kardashiani where every edges
independent of each other
so it can be maybe some some of the
algorithms that aim to words like real
life applications should be tested on
these kind of models instead of like the
more classical ones yeah so do you get
to see the the minus one with the
dimensional representation of v1's ah
yeah okay good question no you don't get
to see that yeah so the graph model
really just samples the graph and all
the information about the vectors are
dropped
and that's a good point
um
okay and another another thing which
will be more of the topic of schools
afternoon talk is that we see that this
introduced some like uh some graph where
locally The Edge is more dense than
globally like globally like we have some
average degree but locally if we just
restrict our attention to the local
neighborhood of a they are like kind of
more well connected than than just some
like random sub graph induced by random
vertices in the graph therefore uh
there's some intuation that it can be
applied to construct a higher
dimensional expenders which are
essentially expander graphs with well
expanding neighborhoods
so uh and this will be like
so we'll talk in the afternoon so this
is a kind of a preview
um okay so that motivates why we are
looking at this model and uh so now we
want to see what's the first question
we're interested in studying for this
model
well
um now we we know that actually as as
was asked before like we're given this
um geometric underlying geometric model
uh underlying geometric structure of
this graph but then when we're given the
graph really we don't get to see the
underlying geometric model
yeah that's it back okay
glad that you're welcome
okay okay yeah so this this went away
yeah so yeah yeah
the vertices went away so okay the
vertices didn't win away but the vectors
went away another question is if we're
only given a graph like this how do we
know whether it comes actually from a um
oh sorry
okay this is unintentional but okay the
point is when we get rid of the
underlying like vector structure where
how are we able to tell like whether
this actually comes from a model like
the random geometric graph model we just
mentioned where it's actually coming
from like an earth shiny model so the
first question is to that of
distinguishing whether a graph comes
from like uh like the order friendly
model or the random geometric model
oh
so to be more precise the two models
we're considering are these on the left
we have GMP which is the early model
where we have like each Edge in the
graph is sample waste probability P
uniformly sorry not uniformly but uh
independently
okay so no underlying geometric
structure and the the one on the right
are is the model that we just mentioned
random geometric model where we sample
from a unit sphere essentially
okay so uh
so yeah so this problem have been
studied before by uh bubachting Eldon
rods in 2016 and they were able to give
a distinguishing algorithm uh in certain
regimes so okay maybe I should mention
that to this distinguishing problem of
course depends on the certain parameters
like in certain choices of D the
dimension of uh the sphere NP this will
be an easy to distinguish problem
however in some other dimension uh with
some other choices BNP it'll be hard and
uh okay just to give some intuition like
when D is really large
like uh
it can be imagined that as as I
mentioned the very beginning the first
slides when we're defining the model
like when D is really large the Tau the
inner product dependency between two
vertices from a random or the shrine
sorry from a random geometric model I
mentioned that their underlying vector
has a threshold that's much smaller so
it kind of decreases the dependency
between vertices
and as a result it's kind of making it
closer to being like a training model
where the vertices are not okay where
the edge one existence of one Edge
doesn't introduce that much dependency
between vertices
this is a very
uh this is some intuition but maybe
what's easier to see is like if we take
the case when D is equal to three so we
have a sphere in the three dimension so
it's essentially a 2d object and you
know every graph on it roughly need to
be planar so that's pretty different
from erdog for any model because yeah a
random graph a murder trendy model
wouldn't be planar yeah yeah maybe you
already said this but was the Tau chosen
so that the edge yes
distinguish right so uh so it's sort of
interesting that here the agency is used
right
oh yeah it's
it's important is
there's number triangles
and if you can think about in the
situation where the edge density is like
uh you know I mean it makes sense the
identity would would help you because
the denser it is kind of the more
information you're getting about the
embedding right like if it is zero then
you just see the empty
and there's no dimension in which you
could hope to test these things right so
it is
right because
it sounds like a very introduction type
thing wait sorry here do you know here
you don't know we know P yeah p is no
you can estimate P super well just by
looking at the average degree in the
graph so that's that that frustrates
[Music]
so here's C1 C2 C3 they all depend on
we don't depend on N actually depends so
the c one is actually one C2 is negative
p and this C3 is P Square
maybe okay I'll talk about this
distinguishing algorithm maybe a bit in
a bit
um it's um
I don't know maybe not so so this this
is essentially a algorithm that's trying
to count to try and go in the following
graph like instead of considering the
graph where adjacency Matrix is just one
and zero indicating whether there is an
edge or not we normally we Center this
matrix by actually
put a minus P to all of the entries and
in this new way to graph you count the
number of triangles so that will give
you basically the parameter as just said
where these structures are all
structures in the original graph
without adding without subtracting that
weight
so it's a counting triangles in the
center graph essentially
uh
yes the uh yeah uh they're they're like
statistical that's correct
so okay
um
right yeah so I was just giving trying
to give some intuition about when D is
small this would be harder to
distinguish but of course all of these
statements so slow mentioned now depends
on P because if p is too large or too
small it's going to be a clique or a
just a bunch of vertices and we won't be
able to distinguish so with a reasonable
choice of Pia there is the sense of like
uh it will be this graph would be closer
to a um when D is larger and this
farther away from it when D is smaller
uh
so this results here uh Bible is saying
like in the distinguishing regime they
proved that for D smaller much smaller
okay here in this talk much smaller
usually means you have a hidden polylog
on the right hand side here
so when D is much smaller than HP Cube
and Cube where this is a binary entropy
function uh of P
then we can use this algorithm to
distinguish the counting the centered
number of triangles to distinguish
and on the other hand when D is much
greater than n Cube uh this is
statistically in this the two
distributions are statistically
indistinguishable
and uh later on
um Brandon wrestler nagaraj have proved
that improved the indistinguishable
bound from an N Cube to like d much
greater than the Min of these two so in
Cube times uh binary entropy of p and uh
HP Cube times n to the seventh hats so
yeah
um this essentially as you making the
bound much better especially in the
regime when he is like
oh um so to summarize the two known
results give us this graph so if we have
x-axis being p uh The Edge density and
the y-axis being the dimension we
consider the distinguishable regime is
this regime here
so it's more specifically in the regime
like uh when Pia's order of 1 over n we
have that we can distinct uh we can
distinguish when D is much smaller than
block Cuban
and we cannot distinguish when a is like
sorry when D is greater than into the
three halves so there's this Gap yeah
just a different uh the red region is
statistically indistinguishable the
green region is also efficient algorithm
this is yeah right this is the efficient
algorithm and this is statistically
okay so
um
okay and in the winter regime like
essentially this Gap is closed into into
the encube yeah
is
uh when p is close to one uh
uh I guess
oh I see I see what you mean uh when p
is close to one I do think it's n Cube I
think it's close to no
oh
okay okay
that's in half but for like an uh
Implement graph Yeah by connecting
further away
those people then studied
okay yeah I should correct myself saying
that this is up to P is smaller than one
half yeah right uh I think yeah
symmetrically in the P greater than one
half regime basically we're studying the
complement graph of the Urdu journey and
the complement graph of this
um random geometric
so this work I'm going to talk about
improve the indistinguishable side of
things and all the Improvement are also
statistically in distinguishability
so we showed that in general
um when D is much greater than HP square
and Cube then uh for uh then basically
this is in this regime random geometric
is indistinguishable from under Trinity
and also specifically we improved that
this result this bound here uh when p is
on the order of one over n to that when
D is much greater than log to the
36 and we have that this is in
statistically indistinguishable from uh
any so there is this gap between log
Cuban and the poly login here yeah this
whole chart should be red or green is it
possible that they're statistically
distinguishable whether it's no
efficient algorithm in some regime
that's a good question
um
I would say I'm I'm not really convinced
by either side yet I would say I don't
have that much intuition so the I mean
there are certain barriers in the
okay so first I want to say like this
lock to the 36 is not heavily optimized
so so it's possible that on this side it
could be close I'm not exactly sure but
in this regime in the middle
um I think I'm more like uh uncertain I
don't I don't know of a way but at the
same time I I also there could be some
also there could be a gap you know
between maybe something is like just not
efficiently distinguishable I think
that's possible to you
foreign
the way that this drawing is drawn it
kind of makes it look like it probably
should do all those red but like what's
really happening is that actually this
Alpha Over N region is like you know
like the x-axis is super not to scale
right so that's actually like a super
thin line and so we're like I mean the
red line extends all the way
but supposedly this should be like in a
tiny slice at the very beginning oh yeah
so so this entire Improvement is only
for order one of it not up to yeah maybe
not up to something
yeah maybe there should be like dotted
lines next time okay so
um right so so okay there's some gaps uh
already pointed out by the audience
um and yeah and this could be some
something that one could look into like
as to whether
whether there should be no like
they should be there should be like uh
nothing
no inefficient algorithm that
distinguish or or it could be like uh
actually some other some other things
other than trying to count Triangle
really distinguishes these things better
we did try yeah
just randomly or it will just randomly
so it still work distinguishing
algorithm yeah I think so yeah it's uh
should be this is pretty robust this
um
yeah
um yeah we've also tried I think um a
couple other I guess also efficient
distinguishing algorithm but none of
them really beats triangle The Sign
Center triangle counting so
so yeah
um but I think inefficient one
okay
so
um next thing I want to do and talk is
really to uh prove this main main Lemma
like uh or give a proof sketch of it so
okay it could be a bit ambitious but
we'll see how much we can get
um so okay so I'm only improving the
here the statement is only for the p is
on the order of one over n case however
I want to say that uh halfway through
the proof we'll obtain the first result
which is for the general choice of P by
the worst bound that I showed in the
previous slide like this one will be
obtained halfway through and later on
we'll optimize for specific choice this
sparse P region okay
yeah so and also imagine
trying to patch stickers and grass by
like adding times randomly and stuff to
fool whatever the distinguishers are
is that like an interesting thing to do
like or yeah
that's true you can try to fool it by
by trying those
that would definitely feel bad algorithm
but maybe there could be some okay even
that I'm not exactly sure because it
also involves counting like uh you know
because that the counter kind of like
Center triangles so
he got it at them in the rough way
either way and sometimes I can maybe
that would work out there I'm not very
sure but I can imagine maybe some more
intricate way some smarter way of adding
triangles
names
oh no it means like uh
even for the basically subtract P oh you
add a minus key to all that weights
so now it becomes to actually either one
minus t or negative p and the U count
triangles in this complete graph
essentially but did you expect the links
to look very different in the two in in
the moments
depending on these
so
but yeah that's an interesting question
okay and the essential way to prove this
statement we just want to show that the
TV distance between the two random graph
distributions are a little one
and uh okay to to improve this maybe
I'll introduce a more sequential way of
viewing the sampling process from these
two models
um
Okay so
I guess uh one can imagine sampling the
the model like uh
by adding one vertex at each time so at
time GT a Time step T we have GT where
it's a subgraph induced by basically the
first T vertices in the in the graph one
through t
and uh given this graph one can
construct a GT plus one by you know
having this vertex and Sample their
neighborhood sample the neighborhood
neighbors of t plus one inside the first
two vertices
this may sound like tautology but this
will make more sense once we actually
start to work on the proof
um
so so yeah so the key uh distribution
that I want to point out here is this
distribution neighborhood of a Vertex so
neighborhood of a vertex t plus one in
the other shiny model we know it's just
a binomial distribution roughly well
exactly
um in the neighborhood if a t plus ones
vertex in the random geometric graph
however will be much more complicated it
will depend uh on GT itself right
we can imagine
um
okay so uh
writer so okay I think I already
mentioned this part
so
let's just review a little bit how this
to how this distribution is defined so
once we're given a graph GT what we do
is we can we can consider what are what
are the vertices V1 through VT on the
random sphere that generates this graph
so this is the distribution of all
eligible like all the vertices all
choices of vectors on the saphir that
generates this GT
okay and once we get a bunch of vectors
for the for uh for the first T vertices
then we can sample with this t plus once
vertex randomly and then look at what's
a distribution of its neighbors okay so
this is a more complicated distribution
to describe
and the I okay so essentially to prove
the statement of the TV distance being
very small
it boils down to just prove like this
two distribution I just introduced the
neighborhood distribution of the teeth
vertex t plus one vertex they're very
close to each other uh their ratio need
to be within one plus minus little one
over square root n this is the this is
the goal we have okay of course this is
with high probability over choices of s
and with high probability over choices
of g t
okay so these are all like uh
probabilistic statement but essentially
this is the this is a real thing we
actually want to prove
um and after that there are some
standard arguments uh that can bring
this bound just into this TB bound
foreign
is everyone clear about what this ratio
means
why you only need square root of okay
um
[Music]
I want to say I'm not sure at this point
yeah I want to think there's some like
let me not try to guess I will give you
an answer afterwards okay
um
and the probability you can think about
the probability over from Champion
like if you can think of it it's not
this is
the formation of GNP and the geometric
graph and if you can couple the
distribution over the neighborhoods of
each vertex that you get the sequence
then you can succeed so then okay
there's some quantitative reasons why we
need this the coupling to be this good
right this is what you're shooting for
you're shooting for such a good coupling
between the distribution of our
neighborhoods uh in the two graphs
and stuff so that's why I like the one
over root n shows up why is it one over
root and not one over n let's not try to
figure that out
actually it seems to me it should be
like the one around squared right
because the other one
right
and the error it's like you could if you
think about it as a stochastic error
then you know maybe you only accumulate
like root like over the end steps maybe
like give me like a rude ends
oh okay
that would be the guess but yeah yeah
but I think that that's that's probably
the the actual
okay so right so okay so now we have
this ratio we want to basically bound
this ratio so it's here okay so
um
to understand this ratio we need to
understand better what's the probability
in the numerator it really is but what's
the probability of having a neighbor
basically having exactly the neighbor
instead being s in the random geometric
model means so essentially we can
imagine okay let's see that we already
have this distribution like condition on
GT we already have a bunch of vertices
or sorry a bunch of points on the Sofia
corresponding to the first T vertices
and each of them around each of them I
draw a sphere cap the saphir cap is what
we had at the very beginning basically
everything in the saphir cap is all the
possible points that could have a edge
with the center here
Okay so
once we have this graph on the first T
vertices then basically each of these
Splinter like each of these small shapes
here with a different color in this
graph they would correspond to a set s
okay so what does that mean basically
instead as for example this let's say
this shape here correspond to just this
vertex because it's only in a severe cap
of this vertex and outside the superior
cap around all the other vertices so
essentially given a set the area or the
Splinter corresponding to the set s this
intersection of all the superior caps
around a centered uh around some vertex
VI where I is in s and also intersecting
with the fact that it's outside all the
other caps
it's not inside us
for vertices that's not inside s
ometimes
the more like um
yeah because this is a pretty important
concept of using later
so basically if for each of the okay if
by Landing a different color here I
would have a different set of neighbors
does that make sense
right and what set of neighbors uh am I
really in depends on like okay in this
color oh
in who's like a severe cab I'm I'm
actually lending it
so the Splendor according to us need to
be the areas that land in all the sphere
caps that
with Centers inside us and not in the
secure caps and then outside the severe
caps where uh with centers outside US
okay okay cool
um all right yeah okay so this
probability then can be essentially be
written as a this the area of this um
the fractional area of this splinters uh
in it's actually expectation under this
distribution where this distribution
we're free to choose V1 to VT SLS they
generate the graph GT
so so yeah this is interpretation of
this probability it's expectation of
area
appreciate
okay so uh essentially we we know that
okay one thing we know really is that um
maybe this is not the right order but
one thing we know is that in expectation
uh
okay yeah let's not say that okay first
attempt to prove that these two are very
close uh we're trying to kind of make
life easier for us but instead of uh
thinking about this probability this
expectation concentrate this this
quantity concentrate in this conditional
expectation we make life easier for
ourselves by looking at removing this
conditional and trying to show that
probability of s concentrate around this
this expectation uh where we remove this
condition so we just randomly sample V1
through BT don't care about what graph
it generates and we want to see if in
already in that case so supposedly
that's a harder case it's harder to to
prove concentration on an unconditioned
uh distribution well okay condition is
making in a reasonable way so usually it
should make it easier to prove
concentration here we want to here it's
making it a bit hard for us because it's
it's a bit hard to imagine like what are
the distributions over V1 through VT
when we require that they have to
generate this GT so we make this
simplification here first by thinking
about uh just this distribution removing
this conditional part okay
all right then um and the the reason
it's first attempt because it actually
fails somewhere but uh it will get
already give us some non-trivial
improvement
okay so when we think about uh just the
just the distribution over the first T
vertices
and we're we're imagining like what's
the probability of s in this
distribution okay sorry I should have
removed this conditioner here
then it's roughly like uh you have a
bunch of severe caps and you're looking
at how this uh how this Splinter evolves
Through Time steps what do I mean by
that if we have an example being like s
is equal to one and two and as
complement equal to three okay in the
first step when we sample a Vertex we
have a severe cap so the Splinter hasn't
appeared yet in some sense in the next
time step uh we have two
we sample the we sample like uh we
sample the V2 at some point now the
Splinter we look at is we're interested
in that generates eventually generates
pointer of s is this intersection
between one and two
and then the third step when we sample s
because uh sorry when we sample vertex
V3 because 3 is not in s so we care
about its intersection with uh three
complement so this is the shape
eventually we care about which is
Splinter
so this is there is some Evolution like
uh essentially these splinters are
generated by the intersection of a bunch
of caps and the anti-caps so we want to
prove that this probability like a sorry
this the area of the Splinter
concentrates and how are we doing this
we're looking at a more
yeah that's right
[Music]
this will be here actually so uh yes
will suggested uh we'll we'll consider
is actually slightly more general
question where we just are given an
arbitrary shape arbitrary like yeah
essentially arbitrary shape L over the
sphere
and now we ask the question like what's
the problem like what's the area
of this shape where which is L intersect
the cap of w
where W is a randomly sampled point on
the Sofia
okay so this is a distribution so we
want to know like the concentration of
the distribution and the of course we
care about what's the expectation well
actually an expectation
a the intersection between L and the
random sphere cap a fractional area
let's say p is equal to P times area of
L
uh this is by let's say a linearity of
expectation
um so what is L supposed to be in the
previous it's the yeah it's a it's
whatever L is an existing intersection
of caps and NT caps and now we're
intersecting with is it with one more
cap for anti-caps so that's yeah that's
what roughly L is
or that's the actual L that we applied
this theorem to but the theorem really
applies to more General as you see this
weird shape here this could also apply
here you are arguing about a worst case
s throughout
but actually you only care about sort of
the typical s that shows up right
uh
uh yeah I would say
um actually this is not really a worst
case that's that uh I'm considering here
I think all of these statements I kind
of drop was high probability but the
difference here though is very important
is that I'm choosing V1 for BT without
restricting that they had to generate a
certain graph I think that's a
relaxation actually made in this attempt
so I'm because as you can see like at
every step I'm just a sampling W
randomly without requiring that W has to
come from a certain area yeah if I
restricted that it will be actually
faithful to the actual expectation
actual probability I want to sit
so this is the
okay so this is the uh this is the
expectation of this quantity P times
error of L that's actually really good
for us uh because actually adding a p
multiplier in in the beginning sounds
really like what's happening in Earnest
training models and stuff uh so now we
really want to know if it actually
concentrates well around this like
expectation
well without really talking about how to
prove this I would just give this
statement uh here and this is uh through
an application of telegrams uh T2
inequalities and some use some optimal
transport results
um
so the theorem just says that okay if
given arbitrary L and the randomly
sample W the area actually is
concentrated well around p with an error
of one plus minus like uh okay let's say
just the square root one over d let's
not worry too much about this thing here
just polylog some poly log Factor
and the also we have a similar result
when L is intersect with a NT cap so
complement of a cap
which also concentrates it concentrates
even better essentially
um
okay
so this is the what we get
but is this good enough for us so that
theorem previous theorem will actually
give us something like the ratio we care
about
um is within one plus minus oh tildev 1
over Square D
that's what that's the that's a that's a
bound we get
we call that our Target like what we
need to get is a little one over square
root in
so there is
okay it depends on your choice of these
so if B is much greater than M poly
login then actually these two are are
the same and we're already good and
actually this if you plug in this choice
of D this is exactly the first result
weaker result that applies for more
General key that we had
okay so this already basically that
concentration this concentration already
get us something some improvement from
in comparison to the previous result but
we want to do a bit better for like uh
when when for D that's smaller like our
Target really like in the theorem is
that we want to do something for D
greater equal to poly login without this
m Factor so we need to do better
where did the slack come from the slack
really come from the fact that uh
we studied
we didn't we didn't really think about
this part we didn't think about oh we
have to make sure that V1 through VT
actually comes from actual had to
generate a specific G we can imagine
once we they have to generate specific G
maybe the graph structure is more rigid
you have to have like certain
relationship between the first the T
vertices and therefore that makes like
uh this probability more concentrated
because the shapes are roughly like
structured like rigid you cannot change
them too much
so the key thing is really to study this
conditional distribution instead of like
the unconditioned distribution
okay so in the rest of the talk I will
okay we still have time to go through
this like what's what's what's changed
in this argument when we had to
condition on GT
so
maybe before that let me say like uh to
make the presentation easier I secretly
relax this ratio we want to get before I
said the ratio we want to get is really
like when the neighborhood is exactly
good to us
um the ratio between the two different
models here I would make the relaxation
just say okay I'm just going to look at
the probability that neighborhood
container subset as
and it suffices for us to get something
and to get the same ratio for this
containment relationship actually
um and I will not really say why
um
but but but yeah it's a bit more
complicated than just inclusion
exclusion
um
okay
so uh
yeah let's uh this is just quickly
recall that how how this distribution is
defined so we have a we have a graph and
we have to sample a random set of
vertices that actually vectors that
actually generous graph and after that
we we look at the possible all possible
neighborhood of a randomly sampled t
plus one vertex foreign
it would be good okay so what's ideal
for us well what's ideal for us is it
would be really nice if every uh if even
condition on this G less or equal to T
every single vertex in every single
Vector for vertices inside the set s
that we chose
is going to be ID and uniform over the
over the sphere
if this really holds then actually we
could see that the probability of a
random Edge can sorry a random vertex uh
a random vertex having s being It's
contained in its neighborhood is p to
the s
again this is because of the expectation
calculation that I omitted here
so next we will show is that with high
probability over choice of GT and also
with Choice over s this will actually be
true that we will actually have have all
these vertices sorry all these vectors
inside the set s being roughly being
roughly independent and uniform
over the severe okay so this may sound a
bit strange like why could we get that
well we actually crucially use the fact
that uh this is a sparse graph so we are
really now in the regime where p is
order of one over n
and let's see why
so
consider this following construing
satisfaction problem on this graph GT
now we impose The Edge construing and
non-edge constraint so the variables are
essentially all the vectors we assign to
the uh to the vertices 130.
and the constraint is that okay all the
all the vertices with edges need to have
like
large in a product and all the non-edges
should have small inner product
so the solution
to this CSP is essentially the set of
all possible uh assignment with non-zero
probability in this conditional
distribution because they are able to
generate the set the graph GT
is this clear
like I'm just defining a CSP here
nothing really happened
but the CSP kind of give a description
of this distribution
you know uniform distribution over the
satisfying assignments of this CSP is
essentially this distribution here
I guess I admitted one thing which is
all the VIS need to be on the units of
here
um
okay once we have this uh we want to
analyze a marginal distribution of a
small set of Vis inside this in this uh
inside of this uh satisfying
distribution before doing that we all
will first make another simplification
which is we drop the non-edge
constraints uh it turns out this doesn't
influence the marginal distribution of
small sets too much so we'll do that
this is it doesn't hurt intuition of the
approach either so
okay
now we actually want to look at this
solution distribution
so so this is a very nice picture so
okay so we we talk about this is the
regime we care about is really the dream
regime of Po of on the order one over n
so why that okay now here's the here's
the real reason the Sparks regime will
guarantee two things first is
um so the GTR sparse so they are locally
tree-like
uh which is drawn like this like this
entire graph is uh GT
and second if we look at uh local
neighborhoods of s
with true we choose some L and look at
the L neighborhood of s they all be
tree-like and also they'll with high
probability be destroyed from each other
so this is a high probability statement
that holds specifically for the sparse
regime so we can have a graph that looks
like this graph here on the left
so once we have this we consider the
following thing we consider any
assignment like any typical well kind of
nice assignment to all the vertices in
the in the middle bulk here so we fixed
all their assignments and look at look
at after we condition on this assignment
what are the conditional distribution
over all these s uh the choice of s
basically the vector is assigned to s
to all the vertices in this
okay so first the claim is that they're
independent in this conditional
distribution
because okay because we fixed everything
in the middle here so after we fix
everything in the middle uh these are
conditionally independent from each
other especially when we remove the
non-edge constraints
maybe I should pause here
because now essentially we're only left
with Edge constraints so once you know
all the roots of the tree is fixed like
uh you know s really depends this Choice
here for example only depends on the
assignment of these vertices not
anything else here because we've dropped
the non-netic constraint
and they're independent from each other
also just because they're they're root
vertices are also destroying sets
this depends right uh depends on what L
okay uh sure it depends yeah it depends
on L and the word true is L to be large
like log n over log login neighborhoods
but
yeah technically not but uh in spirit
yes I think
okay
yeah yeah of course we wouldn't really
get uniform distribution because you
know to generate GT this is definitely
not going no I mean I'm just saying like
the so so the claim that you're written
on the side I think Independence isn't
that difficult to see because it's the
usual reason why if you have like uh
uniformity is like knocked at all easy
to see right right yeah I don't know uh
actually I'm going to explain uniform
you see I just want to explain why
Independence right Independence I guess
okay uh now I see okay yeah okay so this
is independent and uniformity yeah I'm
going to explain it
so essentially uniformity we just need
to single out one thing and improve
uniformity and then independence will
tell us they're all like kind of
simultaneously uniform
Okay so
as mentioned before like
the assignment of this route for text is
what we actually care about and now we
have all the leaf vertex assignment
being fixed
so we now just need to know like when's
the lead vertices are fixed what's the
distribution over the root or text
assignment we want to claim it's uniform
and uh we're showing tuition in a very
simple tree
which is a path
Okay so
we want to know the distribution over V
root given belief
let's say this Green Dot is the leaf
vertex
so and this is this point on the on the
uh on this on the sphere
and now this uh blue circle around it is
the support of its parent right so its
parent is some vertex that actually
connects with the green thing which
means that the distribution of its
parent is really like a uniform
distribution over the sphere cap around
the screen vertex
so
yeah so I will use notation FY for the
PDF for VY
so in general uh when we know the PDF of
a Vertex X and now we want to refer to
infer from it the PDF of its uh parents
in this tree
the the procedure of doing that is
really just you know this distribution
is defined by sampling a random point
from FX and then walk to a random Vector
around a cap in w
and this will generate a new
distribution which is which is its
parents distribution
the clear element in the most degenerate
case where FX is just a
point Mass here on the screen vertex
then its parent will be a uniform
distribution around over the saphir cap
around it and more generally you know
you can always do this for every point
in the support
in this process that's being described
here
or gives rise to a Markov operator p
which essentially you know Walks from
every point to a random Vector to a
random to a random Point around its uh
saphir cap
so we can write in this way we can write
the parent PDF is really equal to
applying the smartcraft operator to the
child's PDF
so more generally like the roots the
distribution is really applying this p l
times to the leaf distribution
and what's left to be shown like we want
to say that this is uniform so what's
left to be shown is that really like
this is a Contracting operator it
contracts the
contracts the distance between uh a
distribution with the uniform stationary
distribution the stationary uniform
distribution over the sphere is the
stationary distribution of this Markov
operator
so we just want to show that it can
track this P operator contracts the TV
distance to the stationary distribution
and the
yeah also using like a similar optimal
transport result we can show that uh
really by applying P to F you actually
contract the TV Distance by a factor of
one over square root d
and with our choice of L then this can
be made into a little of one over square
root and
so essentially the root to vertex is
really those root vertex distribution is
really close to uniform
as a result
that's really accelerated but if if
anything is unclear
you can show it more generally for
graphical posts yeah for more for more
yeah more generally for a tree for
General treat it will be similar but the
analysis is the more tricky just because
yeah you might have multiple children to
get to its parent then there's some
convolution going on
uh yeah
okay
so okay once we're able to get this
uniformity here
no there we get this uniformity of Vis
in set s then we'll be able to prove
this ratio like this containment
probability ratio is within one plus
minus little of one over square root in
and from that we'll be able to get back
to the theorem statement that we want
which is that TV distance is little of
one between the two models
and uh yeah
this will be it we'll see it
how sensitive are the proofs in the fact
that you're on the sphere if I did it on
a three-dimensional chorus or something
has been changed
good question okay I think
so I'm not sure like is there optimal
transport results on the forest because
we heavily use the one that's actually
for the severe
um
so I think that part is really
customized to severe but if something
similar like uh like you can similar
results hold for a manifold that uh
basically balance the optimal transport
the W-2 distance with let's say Chao
Divergence between two distributions
then I think it should many of things
through transport
geometry has also been here pretty
differently like it's not even
statistic is so different means that
maybe like the proof of Industry ability
would also be free
let's I mean let's stop
okay